-Guys, this is my new
holiday single.
I just flipped it around.
[ Laughter ]
This is me and Dolly Parton,
"Almost Too Early
for Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I talked about it on the show
last night because I put it out
on TikTok, and it was taken down
for legal issues.
[ Laughter ]
Because they said they didn't
have the rights to air the song
on TikTok from the owner.
I wrote and sang the song.
[ Laughter ]
I go, "This is impossible."
But anyways, I'm in a legal
battle with myself.
I'm currently in litigation.
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm gonna win.
50/50.
But it's been straightened out.
It is now available.
You can find it wherever on
the TikTok that I put out there.
Which is a very innocent TikTok
of just me saying
how excited I was.
Because you know, everyone
kind of starts this debate,
and now it's getting
earlier and earlier,
but it used to be Thanksgiving.
They have the debate.
They go, "Should we --
can we listen to holiday music?
Can we listen --
Do we play Mariah Carey now?"
[ Laughter ]
And I say, yes.
If it's a good a song,
play it whenever you want.
But anyway, so I thought it'd
be funny if I wrote a song
called "Almost Too Early
for Christmas"...
[ Laughter ]
...and you put it out Halloween.
And so I wrote this song,
and then I didn't know
what to do with it.
And then Dolly asked me
to do a scene in her movie
coming up, called
"Mountain Magic Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'll do anything.
I'll do
whatever you want me to do.
I'll do --
Dolly Parton, sure.
I'll come,
I'll be the camera operator.
Whatever you want me to do,
I'm there.
So I go to Tennessee,
which inspired me for my beard.
And, yeah,
the question no one's asking.
[ Laughter ]
So I go there, and she goes,
"What song do you want to do?
What song do you want to do?"
And she's so cool.
It's Dolly Parton.
And I will say,
I wish that I worked --
I was there in the morning
to the afternoon.
I wish it was 9:00 to 5:00,
but it was 10:00 to 3:00.
[ Laughter ]
I know, I know.
Hey, I can still dream.
But she said,
"What song do you want to do?"
I go, "A song?
I'll do anything with you."
And so we're
going through songs.
I couldn't believe
she wanted to sing something.
I go, "I actually
just wrote this song,
'Almost Too Early
for Christmas,'
could fit in with this theme."
She goes, "I want to hear it."
I go,
"You want to hear this song?"
So I just couldn't believe
ever that she even wanted
to hear the song.
So I'm playing
it off my phone or something.
I'm like, "That's it,"
and she goes, "I love it."
So next thing I know,
I sent the track to her,
and she records it, like, in a
night and sends it back to me
and harmonizes,
and it sounds awesome.
Can we just play
one second of it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ It's almost too early
for Christmas ♪
-♪ Too soon
to be singing this song ♪
That's it!
Stop right there!
No, stop right there!
We can't legally afford it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We can't legally
play that music!
[ Laughter ]
It's too early!
Anyways, right now,
you can go on nothing
and listen to it 'cause...
[ Laughter ]
...legally, it's not out
till Friday morning, so...
But if you can find it
wherever I posted it,
you can listen to that.
And I want to thank you for that
and thank Dolly so much.
It's now almost out.